l'om le psg ou encore le red star 24
équipes se sont donné rendez vous sur
les terrains du stade bernard giroux de
plaisir à l'occasion de la challenge cup
plaisir un tournoi international pour
les moins de 12 ans organisé sur deux
jours les 23 et 24 octobre où les
amateurs ont côtoyé les professionnels
très très bien c'est vraiment très très
basse une expérience pour eux plus tard
à venir comment ça joue commencé là-bas
comment eux comment ça se passe sur le
terrain et voilà et aussi les coachs
c'est tournoi c'était bien parce que il
y à des équipes internationales qu'on ne
pourrait pas affrontés avant longtemps
comme le fc bruges
toulouse des équipes aussi des jets
marseille donc c'est cool de faire venir
des équipes comme ça plaisir et la
première édition de ce tournoi est un
retour aux sources pour le club de
plaisir la structure avait organisé un
autre tournoi international minimes
entre 1981 et 1995 tout c'est vrai que
ça date et à l'époque la sape le tournoi
tall sall minimes et je rends hommage
effectivement mes prédécesseurs ceux qui
sont passés avant moi justement qui
avait mis en place au tournoi et soit là
c'est un petit un petit message aussi
que je leur envoie parce que moi j'ai du
souvenir de ce tournant là et ça me
tenait aussi à coeur en lien avec sa de
remettre ce type d'événement est de voir
tout ce monde là aujourd'hui ça fait ça
fait vraiment plaisir après deux jours
de tournoi c'est le club de bruges qui
remporte la compétition en battant le
football-club 93 en finale les
organisateurs plaisir on espère
désormais organiser un nouveau tournoi
l'année prochaine